what was the brief conversation you had
with Islam marketev and this team I
didn't know how we'd take the joke
because obviously khabib tried to Flying
Eagle kick Dylan Dennis in the face so I
wasn't sure how my humor would go yeah
but I mean Dylan must have said some
worse things to me I was just playing
around I mean you can't really take
anything I say serious yeah come across
like an idiot but so when he was coming
up to me afterwards I was like oh I
don't know what he's gonna say and again
maybe he would have been more upset if
he had lost but he just received the
judge's decision yeah but he came up I
went to check he's saying he gave me a
big hug and then pretended to throw me
and then I thought the interaction was
over and then he circled back so that's
why I was so awkward I was like oh he's
coming back he wants to say he wants he
wants something else but he just said
why didn't you teach your boy how to
escape the body triangle
oh wow interesting what did you say to
that I said well I mean obviously you've
got to learn how to finish a real naked
choke is that what you said
uh and I was laughing but then I should
have said they were like get out of here
before the Aussie crowd attacks here you
know what do you think about the body
triangle position that we're in it
seemed like for the first time it seems
almost like walk was yeah it did
dominant in that position which is kind
of weird I mean damage is meant to Trump
control
MMA judging damage is the number one do
you think the the judges saw that who
what do they score that as I think they
all scored four towards Islam yeah three
and five uh two of the judges scored
towards Volks one of the judges scored
three for Islam one it was 49 46 uh for
one of them and the other ones were 48
47 I think they're again the confusing
round was around so I don't think anyone
scored the body triangle round for a
Volks which I wish they had